20s are a waste of time like don't even  worry about don't try and get it figured  out like you're the point of your 20s is  to try 12 different things and fail at 9  of them  but truthfully in society right now you  talk to so many college kids and they're  so depressed at 2021 because they don't  they haven't gotten the perfect  internship over the summer and they're  not pre-enrolled in the perfect grad  program and they don't have their um you  know their their job aligned now i know  it's hard to make a living out there you  know it's hard to have a career and make  a living it's much harder than in the  80s and 90s when we were you know  getting our educations but  nonetheless if you view the 20s as a  workshop stage then it gives you some so  you can relax a little bit